bonjour bienvenue dans europe hebdo nous
sommes à bruxelles au parlement européen
pour 30 minutes d'actualité européenne
alors dans cette émission nous allons
nous pencher sur les blocages français
marché du travail réforme des
institutions renouvellement de la classe
politique pourquoi la france passe pour
être irréformable à l'heure où des
centaines de milliers de personnes
défilent pas paris et dans les grandes
villes françaises contre la loi sur le
travail de myriam el khomri nous allons
donc nous pencher sur ce mal français
l'immobilisme mais avant d'en discuter
avec mes invités retour sur les
dernières manifestations a tout de suite
sous une pluie battante ils sont entre
400 mille et un million deux cent mille
à battre le pavé dans toute la france
objectif le retrait de la loi elle
comrie sur le travail
on ne lâche rien tout à fait on ne lâche
rien parce que c'est trop grave si c'est
une rupture par rapport au modèle
républicain de la négociation collective
dans notre pays à l'instar de ce qui
s'est fait dans d'autres pays je pense à
l'allemagne je pense à l'espagne au
portugal
côté gouvernement l'heure est à
l'apaisement
quoique qu'il y ait de l'exaspération
dans un pays où il ya un chômage de
masse depuis trente ans et que ces
inquiétudes s'expriment bien évidemment
il faut rester à l'ecoute même si
l'opinion publique ne peut pas être la
seule boussole de l'action
gouvernementale
après plusieurs semaines de bras de fer
entre étudiants lycéens leaders
politiques de gauche et les
syndicalistes le mouvement social risque
bien de s'amplifier là aujourd'hui il ya
des occupations
ça prouve que l'on s'arrête pas après la
manifestation voilà c'est tout ce
mouvement là par rapport à la loi ce
travail qui est en train de naître et
les occupations de places bien entendu
que pour nous c'est aussi une tentative
par rapport à ce qui se passe en espagne
et en grèce
occuper la république depuis la
manifestation du 31 mars le mot d'ordre
est lancé on a une sorte de fenêtre
qu'on veut exploiter pour remettre en
cause le système néolibéral et ses excès
remettre en cause le système néolibéral
à l'image de podemos en espagne au
syriza en grèce un rêve général
alors pourra-t-on espérer voir un jour
ce rêve général se réaliser c'est la
question je vais poser à mes invités
pervenche berès bonjour vous êtes
députée européenne membre du groupe
socialiste et démocrate bienvenue à vous
à côté de vous pascal durand bonjour
donc député européen vous êtes membre du
groupe des verts est en face de vous
jean quatremer journaliste au quotidien
libération vous êtes le spécialiste ici
des questions européennes alors
pervenche beres âge mais je m'adresse à
vous d'abord on voit que les places las
on commence à être occupé notamment à
paris le mouvement s'amplifie un million
de potentiellement trois cent mille
selon la police dans les rues finalement
on va au blocage
je ne le souhaite pas et si on veut le
rêve général c'est sûrement pas un rêve
de blocage et c'est peut-être la
manifestation qu'il ya des choses qui ne
marchent pas bien dans notre pays et où
en tout cas il ya eu un sentiment de la
jeunesse de courir après des mythes
qu'on n'arrive pas à atteindre et c'est
peut-être le signe plus profond je crois
de ce que notre pays a du mal à se
réformer
accepter une certaine forme de modernité
alors selon vous ces jeunes là qu'on
voit dans la rue sont des gens pas très
moderne ne peut être pas dire ce que
j'ai pas dit jeudi qu'il était à la
recherche d'un idéal et du sens à donner
à leur vie à leur engagement et une
inquiétude par rapport à l'évolution de
la société par rapport à leur rôle futur
simplement il faut aussi s'interroger de
savoir qui ces jeunes représentent et à
quoi il aspire profondément la presse
ces jours ci et remplies de papiers qui
me disent mais au fond que veulent ces
jeunes de la place de la république
parce que on voit bien que la question
de la réforme de la loi du travail
c'est peut-être un sujet mais c'est pas
le sujet fondamental qui explique ces
soirées place de la république alors
selon vous jean quatremer sais quoi qui
explique ces soirées place de la
république c'est une envie plus globale
de renverser la table
en tous les cas je m'interroge sur le
sens profond de ce de ce type de
mouvement parce que je remarque la
dernière mobilisation de la jeunesse
et du monde du travail des citoyens
français pour des valeurs c'était en
2002 lorsque jean-marie le pen s'est
qualifié pour le second tour 21 avril et
donc la manifestation du 1er mai
absolument donc là on a vu des gens
défendre des valeurs un modèle
républicain
ensuite ça a été des manifestations
depuis sa nouvelle manifestation pour
défendre le statu quo surtout ne changez
rien
donc ça a été la lutte contre le contrat
première embauche cpe
ça a été la lutte contre la réforme des
retraites est aujourd'hui la lutte
contre la réforme du droit du travail au
moment même où par ailleurs l'europe est
en train de se transformer en forteresse
où on est en train de renvoyer vers la
turquie est un pays très démocratique
comme vous le savez très bien
des centaines voire des bientôt des
milliers des dizaines de milliers de
réfugiés que des gens se noie en
méditerranée que nous nos états sont en
train de se transformer en état
autorisons mayence est pas pour les
bonnes raisons selon vous on ne
manifeste pas pour les bonnes raisons et
en plus ceux qui manifestent on est là
c'est facile en ce sont des lycéens et
des étudiants
c'est à dire des gens qui ne sont pas
touchés par le chômage de masse mais qui
ont du mal à rentrer sur le marché du
travail mais tout le monde je garde en
moi j'appartiens à une génération moi je
suis la génération post 68 j'ai eu du
mal à rentrer sur le marché du travail j
ai enchaîné les stages les vacations etc
c'est il ya gagné 2 me mais non il y
avait dans les années 90 moi je suis
entrée sur le marché du travail
à la fin des années 80 je suis désolé ça
ne fait pas plus simple c'était
difficile et art est un mal français fin
quand on regarde les statistiques du
chômage
exemple pour les gens qui sont formés et
quand je parle pas des gens qui ont un
diplôme en sociologie elle peut se faire
du souci effectivement mais pour les
autres
le taux de chômage autour de 4 5% hier
que ces gens là ça y est on a
effectivement que le diplôme protège du
chômage les drames
drame français c'est en réalité le
système scolaire
elle produit de l'échec en masse et là
vous avez donc là selon vous le problème
c'est quoi c'est qu'on a affaire à une
jeunesse qui cherche à renverser la
table parce qu'elle en a ras-le-bol du
système ou plus globalement c'est
vraiment la loi elle comrie qui pose
problème
écoutez quand j'entends des jeunes dire
dénoncer le système néolibéral dans la
nuit dans la dépense publique est de 58%
ou aucun poste de dépenses sociales n'a
été réduit depuis 25 ans j'avoue que ça
me sidère un peu alors ce qu'un système
néolibéral c'en était au niveau
peut-être des dépenses
public britannique voir américaine la
france est le pays le plus socialiste de
la planète pascal durand qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
exactement la même chose ça vous aidera
pas c'est aussi pour ça qu'on est con
invité d'abord la première chose
j'entends pervenche berès lorsqu'elle
dit que ces jeunes cherchent un idéal
je vais être un peu plus pragmatique qui
cherchent d'abord du boulot et cherche
des formations il cherche à trouver leur
place dans une société qui les laisse
complètement dehors c'est vrai pour les
jeunes mais pas mieux c'est vrai dans
certaines villes c'est vrai dans de
manière générale on a l'impression que
l'arrêt plage du progrès cdi 28-29 alors
justement j'allais le dire parce que et
c'est vrai ce que dit jean quatremer sur
le fait que ça a été dur à d'autres
périodes de la vie peut-être la vôtre
sauf que moi je vois et je le vois par
rapport à mes enfants par exemple
maintenant on leur propose qu'ils soient
diplômés ou pas et ils sont diplômés
mais d'abord et avant tout des stages
sert qu'à 25 ans ou à 26 ans on est
encore à proposer à des jeunes qui le
sont de moins en moins des métiers
précaire bdd 450 euros ou 500 euros qui
leur a interdit d'avoir une vie autonome
mois à 26 ans il se trouve que j'avais
déjà mon premier enfant et que je venais
de prêter serment pour être avocat
donc on avait une capacité d'entrer dans
la société d'entrer dans la vie qui
n'existe plus maintenant donc d'abord et
avant tout c'est la manifestation d'un
d'un sentiment d'être mis carte et
d'être message que ces espèces est
spécifiquement un mal français on parle
de flexisécurité en europe d'une
capacité en fait par un mal français
il y a une il ya dans d'autres pays
alors peut-être parce qu'il ya eu
d'autres conditions de travail donc ça
c'est un autre problème la question de
réformer le droit du travail
ça c'est un autre sujet mais ils ont la
capacité de trouver des jobs est pas
nécessairement des stages comme en
allemagne ou en angleterre qui ont ces
pays que je connais bien les jeunes
trouvent désengage mais après des stages
ou des apprentissages qualifiant et
avant je vais très très important de
bien faire les comparaisons
internationales et notamment européennes
parce que dans la foi parfois
l'impression que la france serait le
pays malade de l'union européenne moi je
regarde franchement aujourd'hui les pays
l'union européenne
je connais pas de champion toutes
catégories
les pays de l'union européenne ne vont
pas très bien ils sont bousculés
beaucoup de choses il ya une interaction
entre leur impuissance à l'échelle
européenne
leur propre impuissance face aux défis
auxquels ils sont confrontés dans la
mondialisation et cela tourne enfin
concernant d'accord pour dire que
résonnent plus pour actionner un levier
européen mais notre capacité de
convaincre pour l'instant on a encore
des marges de progression mais sur le
défi que rencontrent ces jeunes j'ai
parlé d'un idéal parce que moi je me
souviens quand j'avais leur âge j'avais
quand même la vision d'une société où
chacun de trouver sa place et avait 100
l'impression de contribuer à un projet
commun excepté d'un projet commun c'est
quand même quelque chose qui continue à
animer je me semble-t-il cette
génération mais elle est confrontée à
des choses qui sont communes toutes les
jeunesses d'europe et à nos spécificités
dans nos spécificités par exemple la
question de la place du diplôme veut est
une question absolument majeur ce que
disait jean quatremer vous allez au
royaume-uni alors au royaume uni tout
les jobs qui sont offerts à des jeunes
ne sont pas assez rémunérés toujours etc
mais cette disqualification au nom du
diplôme n'existe pas et c'est une des
difficultés que j'ai avec cette réforme
c'est que je pense qu'il y avait enfin
il ya matière en faire une immense
réforme de gauche et la zélande bras
alors dès lors qu'on en fait la réforme
du compte rendu du compte personnalisé
d'activités qui échanger limite de
contrat social finalement et englobe
michael la question de l'éducation la
question à cholet reviendront mais je
rebondis sur ce que disait pascal durand
effectivement c'est il faut s'interroger
il faut regarder l'ensemble du système
quelle est la difficulté des jeunes
aujourd'hui vous trouver un petit boulot
ou un boulot qui est pas très bien payé
au départ le problème ensuite se
trouvait à logements de d'avoir des
garanties de trouver un crédit bancaire
d'avoir des garanties que c'était en
réalité sans télé ni c'est pas possible
voilà absolument à blanc au ces de
l'ensemble du système en bleu qu'est ce
qu'on a fait par exemple au canada c'est
très intéressant pour garder le canada
en 95 le pays était en faillite
là on a pas on n'a pas mégoté parce que
c'est un pays plutôt tadis anglo saxon
on a coupé à mort dans les budgets
sociaux
mais qu'est ce qu'on a fait on a enlevé
par exemple les
qui allait aux plus riches questions
familiales des plus riches et on l'a
divisé leur montant par deux et on a
tous réorienter vers des classes les
plus pauvres
le résultat c'est qu'aujourd'hui au
canada c'est le taux d'illettrisme
padaré fraitis d'illettrisme le plus bas
du monde occidental
de même sur le logement qu'est ce qu'on
a fait on a libéralisé complètement le
logement c'est à dire que lorsque vous
ne payez pas votre loyer vous êtes viré
votre logement en deux semaines ne veut
pas de trêve hivernale à bordeaux
le résultat c'est quoi ouais c'est à
dire que vous vous et votre joueur à
n'importe qui vous demandez pas d'écart
on est garante des gars est
effectivement aussi le cas vous dites je
m'engage à payer moins
et puis vous trouver les moyens ce qu'il
faut faire moi je voudrais alors
rebondir je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec jean quatremer c'est celle là
dessus je partage à 100 % pour le crédit
s'est pareillement il on aurait pu on
pourrait imaginer en france une garantie
des loyers pour les étudiants pour ceux
qui n'ont pas la capacité à la presse
qu'elle les parents etc etc
mais moi je voudrais quand même revenir
sur une des raisons du blocage
j'entends le fait qu'on a du mal à
réformer mais comment se fait-il
comment se fait-il que la gauche arrive
au pouvoir après des années avoir
critiqué le gouvernement et à juste
titre notamment de nicolas sarkozy et
elle arrive au pouvoir
et on attend la quatrième année c'est à
dire quasiment la fin du mandat du
président de la république et du
gouvernement pour réformer le droit du
travail comment se peut-il alors que
c'est une priorité pour la gauche que le
président de la république avait dit
l'emploi des jeunes notamment et la
priorité des priorités et il avait
raison de le dire et je sais pervenche
berès fait beaucoup en europe avec nous
pas seul mais pour faire en sorte la
garantie jeunesse etc
comment se peut-il c'est ça le problème
de la france est de venir quand on
arrive au pouvoir
on a l'impression que soit on n'est pas
préparé à réformer donc ça c'est la
faute de la classe politique il
deuxièmement pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'a
pas utilisé la première ou la deuxième
année à faire valoir nous vous le savez
est question parce que la france est
dirigée par des lancers dirigés par des
fonctionnaires
la mère qui on décide en mission de tels
avantages qui se pose pas la question
c'est à dire surtout non mais on peut
pas non plus dire que rien ne s'est
passé parce que je devais alors il ya eu
maille à gelos et d'amérique man 4 par
exemple sur la question de
l'investissement faire en faveur de
l'éducation
je ne dis pas que tous aient transformé
par des investissements qui sont
immédiatement avec des résultats
nous restons un pays totalement
paradoxal quand on est le pays où les
enfants rentrent les premiers à l'école
dès l'âge de deux ans on est les
champions d'europe pour ça même si le
chiffre baisse est à l'autre bout de la
chaîne on est les champions de ceux qui
sortent sans qualification
il ya un volet qui moi me semble très
important c'est que aujourd'hui avec le
fonctionnement de la démocratie avec le
fonctionnement des médias
la question du dialogue social potvin
question absolument majeur alors je ne
sais pas si c'est une question
institutionnelle je ne sais pas si c'est
lié à la nature des syndicats je
n'accuse personne on est dedans ça mais
je vois bien qu'une réforme de cette
nature si elle n'est pas portée par un
profond dialogue social politique et
qu'il a pas beaucoup
on en en arrivait un blocage et c'est
effectivement ce à quoi on assiste
d'ajustement peut-être que ça va nous
ouvrir encore plus sur un autre blocage
français qui est du coup le peu de
renouvellement de ses élites et donc de
sa classe politique et donc de sa classe
syndicale et cetera exactement ça va
avec donc on a été voir chez le voisin
suédois
comment cette politique s'organise cette
politique de renouvellement fait un
reportage de solenn nicolas est un
montage de yoann loiseau
c'est un modèle dont on vante la
réussite
le fameux modèle scandinave en suède une
monarchie parlementaire
le système politique met le citoyen au
centre des décisions cet après midi à
l'hôtel de ville de stockholm
lorenzo vat 26 ans presse le pas le
jeune ténor de la politique suédoise est
attendu à la réunion de son parti les
verts
l'objectif préparer le prochain conseil
municipal
à l'ordre du jour le trafic dans la
capitale suédoise
c est autour de la table la moyenne
d'âge n'est pas très élevé ici on a
vraiment ce sentiment d'être plus
intelligent quand on est avec des gens
différents de nous si tu es jeune tu as
ton mot à dire
tu as forcément des compétences à
apporter et c'est bien ça le but de la
démocratie représentative incarner la
société dans sa diversité
s'il est l'un des jeunes visages du
paysage politique suédois
lawrence thauvette est pourtant loin
d'être un novice on sent un porte parole
des jeunes verts il siège aujourd'hui au
conseil municipal de la capitale
une ascension qu'il attribue notamment à
ce modèle qui facilite le renouvellement
et l'accession des jeunes à la vie
politique
c'est plutôt facile en suède d'entrer en
la politique ce n'est pas quelque chose
que tu apprends c'est peut-être une
chose en laquelle tu crois profondément
poitiers watch hybride scrutin
proportionnel et consensus sont les clés
de ce modèle qui allège les devoirs du
citoyen quand un français doit se rendre
dix fois aux urnes un suédois ne s'y
rendra qu'une seule fois
résultat aux dernières législatives un
taux de participation de plus de 83% une
régulation plus simples de la vie
politique et une conception anti
élitiste de l'exercice du pouvoir
l'actuel premier ministre
syndicalistes de longue date et soudeur
de métier qu'est ce qui fait l'homme
politique il est façonnée à travers des
expériences collectives
je pense le syndicat s'en aller mais on
est dans un pays où le taux de
syndicalisation approche à 80% donc ya
pas de d'école qui façonnent les élites
politiques vous avez des cursus de
sciences politiques mais vous n'avez pas
de une école nationale d'administration
qui produit en fait d'aider et dit avec
des discours parfois parfois semblables
les singes m
aïda asiatique et l'un des symboles de
son modèle et de l'état providence
suédois
ma vie a débuté avec la guerre la mort
les camps de réfugiés et beaucoup de
pertes du maine engagé en politique à 16
ans vice maire d'une ville suédoise à 23
elle est l'un de ces exemples de
personnalités politiques issues du
terrain en 2014
elle devient à 27 ans la plus jeune
ministre de l'histoire de la suède
la plupart des gens ne me croient pas
quand je leur dis que je n'avais pas
prévu d'être à cette place aujourd'hui
quand je me suis engagé en politique
cependant je ne pense pas faire de la
politique
toute ma vie je crois que les gens qui
restent trop longtemps en finisse par
être déconnecté de la réalité
vous avez une formule en suédois qui est
ça signifie que c'est une mission ou de
confit parce qu'on a confiance en toi
si cette confiance tu dois la mériter
les garder en tête que c'est temporaire
chose en suède si on entre tour
politique on reste aussi souvent moins
longtemps au pouvoir
représentativité proximité avec les
citoyens
le modèle social-démocrate suédois a
aussi été forgé par les mouvements
féministes aujourd'hui au parlement
les femmes sont presque aussi nombreuses
que les hommes pour caroline et nice
étudiant en sciences politiques il reste
cependant des points à améliorer
lors de la campagne interne du parti
dans lequel je suis engagé une femme
s'était portée candidate
et il y avait eu de vives discussions
autour du fait que
cette femme représente elle partit alors
on pourrait perdre beaucoup de votes
masculins
le modèle politique suédois dont le
scrutin proportionnel et le consensus
force parfois les parties à des
coalitions a été remis en question 2014
la formation du centre droit s'était
alors allié à l'extrême droite
la suède doit faire face aux mêmes
nombreux défis que les autres pays
européens
son système de renouvellement est donc
précieux dans le contexte actuel alors
peut-on imaginer importer le modèle
suédois en france jean quatremer vous y
croyez est-ce que c'est impensable
d'imaginer qu'une femme de 23 ans
si de réfugiés soit un jour maire d'une
ville de 50 mille habitants à elles
trois ans non ça c'est pas totalement
impossible
honnêtement d'ailleurs on l'a bien vu ne
serait-ce qu'à paris avec les biens
comme delanoë gars qui aurait pensé que
le lot et sur un jour maire de paris il
avait pas 23 ans pour le pp 23 ans mais
je la fais quand même carrière il avait
un profil qui était pas du tout le
profil habituel
c'est possible mais accéder aux plus
hautes sphères de l'état
ça c'est impossible il faut
impérativement avoir fait l'ena ou
polytechnique sciences po avant c'est ça
la réalité de la grande école aux
grandes écoles on a un problème
vis-à-vis du diplômé d'une grande école
vous avez ces demandes archers
république allemande archi républicaine
c'est dire qu'on est on est on est face
à des gens aider les citoyens sont
largement responsables c'est à de fait
les citoyens se moquer de jean pierre
raffarin par exemple qu'il n'était pas
un énarque qui ont qui ne parlait pas
comme l énarque et tous les citoyens se
moquer de lui en revanche des citoyens
adore les énarques
quand est ce que le parti de marine le
pen par exemple et de voeux à percer
dans l'est dans les dents et dans l'est
dans les sondages dans les élections à
m'intéresser à adjoindre un énarque qui
parle comme un énarque en laye en finale
go wi phélippeau 2.2 sous parties etc
regardez tous les chefs de partis sont
tous des mêmes dire que ces apparats par
françois bayrou est effectivement chez
les verts qui sont les deux parties qui
françois bayrou s'est pas à partie alors
comment ils savent qu'on supprime les
grandes écoles est ce qu'on supprime les
grands corps et je crois que c'est une
contradiction polonaise absolument
formidable et qui va très loin
parce que derrière cette question des
grands corps elle est majeure
moi je connais pas tous les jours bien
enfin trop souvent des cas de blocage de
nomination en raison du fait que la
candidat le candidat n'est pas sorti des
grands corps les exemples sont multiples
mais derrière ça il ya un mythe français
qui est fragilisée puisque le mythe
française c'est quand même celui de la
république qui perd la salle lorsque
j'allais à l'un des siens or aujourd'hui
ce mythe est en miettes
l'ascenseur social ne fonctionne plus et
cette question des corps elle est
autobloquantes pour toute la société
française est derrière moi je vois si on
va jusqu'au bout du raisonnement est
bien à chaque fois qu'on parle des
institutions françaises et à la question
de savoir si on doit aller vers un
régime parlementaire ou un régime
présidentiel et il ya un espèce de
tabous comme un préalable qui est que
les français sont attachés à l'élection
présidentielle et que donc on peut
penser ce qu'on veut sauf ne touchez à
cette pièce de l'édifice et derrière ça
la fonction pyramidale de l'élite se
reproduit quasiment pièces par pia l'art
beaucoup d élevage gagneront des
condamnés à une société verticalement 90
d'abord le premier problème y sommes
enfin le premier prime c'est la
consanguinité
effectivement le fait que toute la
classe politique cet entre soi même
moule exactement marionnettes se connaît
on pas et c'est donc cette consanguinité
qui n'existe quasiment qu'en france la à
ce stade ça c'est un premier problème ni
un deuxième problème n'y a pas de
passerelle entre la vraie vie entre le
monde des entreprises le monde syndical
le monde étudiant et c'est effectivement
ce sont des sociétés sa balle elle ne
résoudra pas bien le notaire ou pas
immédiate immédiate et oriane entend
boris johnson ce ne serait pas possible
chez nous c'était simple qui est
mauricienne saint jean le maire de
lumumba wii et qui était inquiété et qui
est aidé dans mon ancien collègue lice
il a été correspondant pendant cinq ans
à bruxelles - laquelle est grave le
deuxième donc le deuxième problème celle
donc l'absence de passerelle et le
troisième c'est que on voit des conflits
d'intérêts qui naissent de plus en plus
entre la haute fonction publique et la
haute fonction privée parce qu'on a des
pantoufles aise mais il est pire que ça
on fait des allers-retours monsieur
macron il a été inspecteur général des
finances
hop il part dans le privé il va dans une
et il revient comme ministre d'état et
ce serait possible ailleurs par exemple
ça jean quatremer est ce que d'autres
pays permettrait en fait soufflage
non mais je veux dire que dans tous les
pays par exemple aux états unis qui est
amenée à nos exemples il est clair que
pour par exemple les gens qui sortent de
la ivy league c'est à dire des grandes
universités seront trop goût au
gouvernement du gouvernement passe dans
les médias dans les médias passent dans
les banques systémiques anosy paul
système c'est à dire que quand elle qui
perdent une élection c'est fini voilà ne
vais pas le cacher nous par exemple
quand on voit aujourd'hui c'est au tour
de la primaire de la droite nicolas
sarkozy potentiellement françois fillon
alain juppé premier ministre en 95 ce
serait impensable ailleurs c'est ça ne
fonctionne pas comme ça ailleurs de la
même manière que ailleurs vous ne
verriez pas l'ancien directeur du trésor
devenir le patron de chez psa ou de nous
pour reprendre un exemple de gauche
asetek à lever pour la droite et à
gauche et schmelzer qu'il fait la même
chose chez renault donc on passe sa
revanche des récents mois je crois que
sur la question de la fonction d'élu du
statut d'élu il ya des tabous qu'on n'a
pas réussi à lever jusqu'à présent par
exemple pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'a pas
une règle sur la limite d'âge
un goût pour l'élection pourquoi est-ce
qu'on n'a pas un vrai statut de l'élu
qui fait que vous rentrez vous sortez et
que vous n'êtes pas y compris dans cette
affaire du cumul on est aussi les
champions d'europe du cumul journée et
moi je sais que au parti socialiste
martine aubry avait organisé un
référendum aux maux des militants qui a
été massivement soutenu et cette réforme
du cumul n'est toujours pas en place et
c'est ça aussi qui peau nue les jambes
des gens les gens les citoyens sont pas
innocentes faire parce que nous avions
des contradictions pour que la loi
intervient là dessus raison de plus pour
que les mandats soit limité dans
l'espace et dans le temps chez les
écolos ça se passe très bien ça tourne
donc on a on n'a pas de subir ça non là
je parle de le renouvellement des
mandats ni victor shum effectivement il
ya d'autres choses qui bloque puis chez
les écolos mais finalement c'est un peu
logique qu'on ait des occupations place
à l'image de feu des mots ça n'est pas à
l'image de l'écologie c'est pour revenir
donne à la fois à ce pays à la fois des
jeunes femmes et idées et des jeunes
tout court c'est à dire que on voit bien
qu'avec le le renouvellement des mandats
qu'elle que soit après et on a souri
tout à l'heure mais la vérité c'est
qu'on peut le faire
on peut le faire dès que ces pressions
des statuts et ça marche et donc on a la
capacité de le faire dans les autres
partis alors finalement quand on voit
ses occupations de places avec cette
envie de renouvellement cette envie de
changement
est-ce qu'il faut pas s'attendre
effectivement est-ce que ça déclenche
quelque chose il faut l'espérer qu'il
soit un élément déclencheur mais ce qui
s'est passé au cours des 15 dernières
années montre que ce n'a jamais fait
plutôt été un feu de paille
lorsqu'on a retiré le cpe ça s'est
terminé du jeu aux laonnois là et est ce
que la situer les regarder ce qui se
passe avec podemos en espagne finalement
si nous aimons ce n'est pas que des
étudiants et des lycéens s'étaient
l'ensemble de la société qui se révolter
contre sa classe politique qui avait
mené le pays à la faille et la france
n'en est pas là l'affront n'est pas
encore assez dans la criirad française
le vote front national
et c'est bien plus grave voilà où il
faudrait je rêve d'un pot demos hélas ce
que nous avons en france et front
national au dessus sur la place du front
national je pense qu'il ya quelque chose
de très spécifique à la france ça c'est
le renouvellement politique finalement
ce front national chez les hommes dans
leur élan donné cette situation alors
qu'on est quand même un pays où il ya
des choses absolument formidable qui se
passe et je dire tout le monde a salué
le succès de la cap 21
la conférence sur le climat et la coupe
et le le changement climatique ça a été
un succès qui a été porté par donc c'est
que c'est possible finale mais quelle
est aujourd'hui la transformation de ce
à quoi est-ce que ça imprimé dans le
pays va finalement se verra finalement
donc je dors toujours problème c'est que
derrière il faut un nom mais je répète
le problème de la france c'est sa
capacité à mettre la société auralog en
débat et effectivement quand il ya des
blocages et les gamins ont eu raison de
se révolter contre le cpe parce que ça
portait atteinte à leur dignité
simplement derrière il y a eu tort le
gouvernement n'a pas été en capacité
d'essayer de proposer autre chose et de
ne pas être simplement dans le refus et
dans le blocage bon il faut réformer
il faut débattre il faut se respecter
c'est ça le blocage la la rance d'abord
et avant tout alors on verra bien ce que
ça donne d'ici quelques semaines et on
verra ça dans la rue merci à tous merci
à vous d'avoir participé à ce débat
merci à vous nous avoir éclairé vous
retrouver la semaine prochaine ahmed
tazir depuis strasbourg quant à nous
c'est fini
ciao
oh